emilia trabaja en una tienda de música
reparando guitarras ella ha estado dando
seguimiento del tipo de guitarras que ha
reparado y del tipo de reparaciones que
ha hecho
desafortunadamente emilia escribe
desordenadamente y cuando su gerente le
pidió sus registros ella no pudo leer
todos los números las tablas de
frecuencia absoluta y relativa
presentadas a continuación muestran los
números que emilia puede leer puedes
ayudarla a obtener el resto y bueno de
hecho solo copie y pegue las tablas de
frecuencia absoluta y relativa de aquí
las copié y las pegue en mi pequeño
cuaderno de apuntes ahora analizamos
cada uno de estos que está pasando aquí
aquí se muestran las frecuencias
absolutas y aquí las frecuencias
relativas ella no puede leer esto esto
más esto va a ser esto
este dato la cuerda rota de las
acústicas más la reparación del cuello
de las acústicas es igual al total de
guitarras acústicas que ha reparado
estos son los números absolutos y aquí
están los números relativos por ejemplo
el porcentaje de fila esto nos dice que
este número de aquí
el 61 por ciento de este número de acá
y que este número 70
38% de este número de aquí
veamos si podemos utilizar esa
información para obtener esos valores y
como siempre te invito a que pausa el
vídeo y lo pienses por tu cuenta
así que solo para simplificar nombraré a
los datos faltantes con letras para
poder reconocerlos entonces llamaré a
este lo llamaré
llamemos a este
y llamemos a este b
y están diciendo que este valor de aquí
es x x es este valor de aquí así que
dejaremos ese valor como x veamos lo que
podemos resolver así que sabemos que
ella reparo 70 cuerdas rotas de
eléctricas y eso es el 38% del total de
cuerdas del total de cuerdas rotas que
reparó una manera de pensar en eso es 70
y déjamelo círculo
sobre d
esto va a ser el porcentaje de cuerdas
rotas que reparo de guitarras eléctricas
y eso lo dicen aquí eso va a ser 38
puntos 89 por ciento así que eso va a
ser igual a y podemos escribirlo como 38
puntos 89 % ó 38 punto 89 sobre 100 o
podemos sólo escribirlo como
0 punto
889 y esto es claramente lo mismo que
esto es lo mismo que
punto
por ciento
y como resolvemos para ver aquí
bueno podemos multiplicar ambos lados
por b y obtenemos 70
es igual a 0.38
por d
o que ve
y sólo divide ambos lados por 0.3 889 b
es igual a 70 sobre 0.38
89 y podemos sacar nuestra calculadora
para eso entonces tenemos 70
dividido entre 0 punto
889 es igual a 179 ahora ella no va a
arreglar una fracción de cuerda rota por
lo que creo que es seguro decir que
redondeamos al entero más cercano por lo
que parece que arreglo un total de 180
180 o más bien que de 180 el total es de
180 cuerdas rotas así que b es igual a
bueno si veis igual a 180 sabemos que a
más 70 es igual a 180 así que a debe de
ser 110
180 menos 70 es igual a ciento
y ahora podemos obtenerse que es igual a
110 más 21 que es 131
y finalmente de es igual a 180 más 82
que es igual
262 y todo lo que tenemos que obtener
ahora es el valor de x
veamos x es
x es el porcentaje si vemos las
reparaciones de cuello el porcentaje de
la columna de reparaciones de cuello de
acústicas
así que reparaciones de cuello de
las reparaciones de cuello de acústicas
de aquí
es el porcentaje de la columna por lo
que queremos decir
qué porcentaje es 21 de 131 así que x si
no me equivoco va a ser igual a 21
dividido entre 131 y podemos confirmar
eso que lo estamos leyendo bien porque
61 61 dividido entre 131
tiene que ser igual a este porcentaje de
la columna
esto solo es para verificar si estamos
leyendo esta tabla correctamente
entonces es 61 dividido entre 131 es
igual a 46 puntos 56 % que es
exactamente lo que tenemos ahí
así que para obtener x solo hay que
dividir 21 entre 131 21 dividido entre
131 es igual a 16.03 16.03 por ciento
entonces x
x
punto 0 3% y hemos terminado